se nos pregunta cuáles son el dominio y
el rango de la función seno y para
pensar en esto dibujemos la función seno
y lo que tengo yo aquí es una
herramienta para facilitarnos la
existencia
entonces en el lado izquierdo yo tengo
un círculo unitario voy a quitarle este
pedazo que sobra
ahí está mejor y tengo un círculo
unitario en el lado izquierdo y voy a
usarlo para averiguar los valores del
seno de theta para un ángulo theta dado
entonces en el círculo unitario esto es
esto es x y esto es james y bueno
podríamos visualizarlo como para un
ángulo theta dado a intersecta al
círculo unitario y la coordenada y en
ese punto será seno de teta ajá entonces
en este punto será seno de teta y de
este lado tenemos ayer en el eje
vertical aquí voy a graficar de igual a
seno de teta la función de iguala seno
de teta mientras que en el eje
horizontal no voy a graficar a x no yo
voy
graficar aquí en el eje horizontal
atleta podemos ver la teta como la
variable independiente itt estarán en
radiales entonces esencialmente lo que
haremos es elegir un montón de valores
para testar y ahí llegaremos a lo que es
seno de teta es luego lo graficar hemos
y voy a poner aquí una tabla entonces
aquí tenemos en esta columna los valores
para teta y aquí seno aplicado a cada
valor de teta entonces podríamos poner
un montón de valores para testar
podríamos iniciar con que te gusta
digamos 0 entonces con teté igual a 0
que será entonces seno de teta contesta
igual a 0 cuando el ángulo es 0 cortamos
al círculo unitario aquí y la coordenada
ayer de esto será 0 cierto entonces este
es el punto el punto 10 la coordenada 0
por lo tanto seno de teta es igual a 0
cuando te 30 seno de 0 es igual a 0 y
ahora vamos a intentarlo con teta igual
a qué te parece api sobre 2 entonces
igual a pi sobre 2 sólo estoy haciendo
los sencillos si te atreves igual lápiz
sobre 2 es lo mismo que un ángulo de 90
grados entonces nos ubicamos aquí justo
aquí en el eje de las yes y donde corta
al círculo unitario es justamente aquí
aunque punto es este es el punto 0.1
cierto claro que sí entonces que es seno
de pi sobre 2 seno de pi sobre 2 es
simplemente la coordenada jr
eso es uno baja entonces seno de pi
sobre 12 es 1 y sigamos con esto tal vez
veamos un patrón si seguimos con esto
así que vamos alrededor del círculo
unitario y pensemos en qué resultado
tendremos cuando qué te parece cuando
teta es igual a pi que resultado vamos a
tener entonces cuando te traes igual a
piqué seno de pi interceptamos al
círculo unitario justo aquí
esa es la coordenada menos 10 cierto
esto es menos 10 seno es la coordenada
ayer por lo tanto este es el valor para
seno de pi 0
y ahora vamos con tres pies sobre dos y
ya hemos viajado por el círculo unitario
tres cuartas partes hemos llegado hasta
aquí quiere decir que interceptamos
justo en este punto y basándonos en esto
que es seno de tres pisos sobre dos este
punto de aquí es el punto 0 - 1 ajá
entonces aquí es el punto cero como
menos 1 por lo tanto este 930 donde te
traes 3 piso sobre 2 en este caso el
valor para el seno de 3 piso sobre 2 es
menos 1 baja entonces aquí es cuando te
talles 3 pi sobre 20 de teta es igual a
menos uno menos uno y ya que estamos con
esto acabemos de recorrer el círculo de
una vez entonces contesta igualados pi
qué pasa cuando teta es igual a 2 pi ahí
tenemos ahí ya hemos recorrido todo el
círculo unitario y hemos regresado al
punto de partida y la coordenada y en
este punto es cero
por lo tanto seno de dos pies cero y si
seguimos dando la vuelta vamos a tener
el mismo resultado vamos a ver vamos a
ver que se cumple un patrón y ya con
todo esto ahora intentemos graficarlo
así que cuando teta es igual a cero aquí
cuando t t es igual a cero seno de teta
es cero y cuando te traes igualan a pi
sobre dos seno de teta es uno entonces
voy a usar la misma escala baja esto es
entonces seno de teta es igual a 1 esto
es 1 en este eje y así vamos a seguir
entonces cuando cuando usted es igual a
amd ati seno de teta es otra vez cero
regresamos al cero y aquí ahora cuando
cuando teta es igual a tres piso sobre
dos será más o menos por aquí más o
menos aquí es 3 pi sobre 2 entonces seno
de teta es igual a menos 1 usamos otra
vez la misma escala
aquí está menos uno bueno mejor un poco
más abajo aquí está bien aquí está menos
uno por lo tanto seno de teta es menos
uno cuando teta es igual a 3 piso sobre
2 y cuando te des igualados pi seno de
teta es cero baja entonces este tres
igualados pi seno de teta es igual a
cero y ahora voy a graficar esto
entonces tú puedes intentarlo con puntos
entre los puntos que yo he hecho puedes
poner otros puntos y la gráfica se va a
mirar algo así es mi mejor intento de
retrasar esta gráfica se mira se mira un
tanto así
entonces bueno pues ahí lo tienes pero
claro esta no es la gráfica completa
aquí no termina podemos podemos seguir
podríamos agregar otro pi sobre dos y si
hacemos eso si vamos a este punto
regresaríamos al punto en el cero
regresaríamos a seno de teta igual a uno
estaríamos nuevamente en este punto y
puedes seguir y seguir y seguir
ahora si agregas otro pi sobre dos
llegadas-- nuevamente a este punto
llegarás aquí y entonces la curva o la
función seno de teta está definida para
cualquier valor de teta cualquier valor
real de theta que tú escojas y que pasa
con los negativos mientras sigues
incrementando theta así seguimos
recorriendo el círculo unitario y este
patrón emergen pero
qué pasa cuando vamos en la dirección
negativa veamos qué sucede qué tal si
tomamos a menos sobre dos y eso eso va
justo aquí ahí es justo donde
interceptamos al círculo unitario la
coordenada y en ese punto es menos uno
entonces seno de menos piso de dos es
menos uno y podemos ver que así continúa
continúa entonces seno de teta está
definido para cualquier número positivo
o negativo para cualquier ángulo teta
cualquier ángulo teta en el que sea ya
sea positivo o negativo cero para
cualquier número así es entonces bueno
regresando la pregunta la pregunta dice
cuál es el dominio entonces cuál es el
dominio cuál es el dominio
pongo aquí dominio cuál es el dominio de
la función seno y bueno sólo como un
recordatorio el dominio de una función
son todos los valores para los cuales la
función está definida entonces son todos
los valores para los cuales aplicando la
función a esos valores arroja un valor
válido un valor correcto así que cuál es
el dominio de la función seno bueno ya
lo vimos esto lo vimos antes vimos que
podemos tomar cualquier valor para theta
podemos decir entonces que el dominio
son todos los números reales todos los
números reales y ya con esto qué pasa
con el rango con el rango entonces bueno
sólo como repaso el rango algunas veces
en clases de matemáticas un poco más
técnicas llaman al rango la imagen es el
conjunto de todos los valores que toma
la función entonces cuál es este
conjunto son cuáles son los valores de
la función ya iguala seno de teta que
esta función toma y bueno podemos ver
que sigue entre 1 positivo y luego va a
1 negativo entonces
y uno positivo va a uno negativo y
después otra vez sube a uno positivo
después otra vez baja a uno negativo y
así entonces oscila entre estos dos
valores entre estos dos números está
oscilando uno y menos uno puedes ver que
seno de teta es menor o igual a uno y
mayor o igual a menos uno por lo tanto
el rango el rango de seno de teta es el
conjunto de todos los números entre
menos uno y uno incluyendo los extremos
por eso pongo estos corchetes espero te
haya servido nos vemos